we interrupt your broadcast to bring you
this breaking news bulletin the local
malodorous public nuisance known as mr.
jacksepticeye has caused absolute
devastation after tapping into his
negative brain power in an attempt to
promote a new cloak collection available
at cloak brand calm according to
scientists spelling errors were never
intended nor expected to be made at such
a high volume the compounding effect
reaching critical mass and unleashing an
explosion of idiocy that devastated the
local countryside the blast wave of
stupidity lowered IQs as far as 30
kilometers away from the epicenter of
where the quote content was originally
uploaded an explosion of this type will
usually lead to a burst of [ __ ]
particles being generated which are
carried high into the atmosphere and
eventually fall back down in what
scientists call stupid rain the culprit
mr. jack the grammar butcher sceptic guy
is still at large
however he can be identified by his
howler monkey style screech which is
audible from up to five kilometers away
or by his horrendous body odor which is
identifiable from the same distance in
brighter news local national celebrity
handsome hero markiplier wins beauty
contests modeling the new future was now
collection available now at cloak brand
calm throngs of fans caught up with him
after the big win and he was quoted as
saying I didn't even know I was
competing I was just on my way to the
local animal hospital after saving a
litter of orphaned kittens from a
burning tree in the runway just so
happened to be the shortest route there
I'll be donating my winnings to that
hospital as soon as I arrived and if
that wasn't enough after saving and
finding homes for every single one of
those orphan kittens the majestic
markiplier went on to win the handsome
contest being held next door more
information about this story and
additional pictures of the handsome
markiplier can be found through the link
in the description below or you can go
directly to cloak brand calm to see it
all for yourself this concludes our
breaking news bulletin we now return you
to your regularly scheduled programming
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to GTFO the only
difference this time is that I am alone
I am absolutely 100% alone I've been
playing it on my own just to see if I
can get a grasp of the mechanics and try
to get through the game without crapping
my pants
but I've also discovered that I can get
past the first door and clear several
rooms by myself if I'm careful
the only impedin factor might be the
door with the key in it but I don't know
so I'm curious can can I beat the first
level on my own I doubt it
so if it wasn't immediately obvious and
it probably is immediately obvious I
gotta be really careful and really quiet
if I want to have any choice or any
chance of actually doing this whether or
not this is actually gonna happen is
going to be very probably up to me being
able to get enough items but also it
might just be flat-out if possible this
game is designed for four players it is
just intended for that to happen if
you're going into it with less than that
you're not gonna have a good time
oh hey bud by the way glow sticks do not
do anything to enemies so I learned
something else about the enemies in here
you can beat the crap out of enemies
that are pretty close to each other it's
just that any other enemy nearby cannot
be glowing like I can give these two
next to each other but that one cannot
be glowing when I hit this one and I
just gotta hope there's nothing else in
the area
[Music]
I did not check if there was nothing
else around and it sounds like there was
see poopsie I'm gonna go this way real
quick I I have to say I love this game
I love it a lot I love it so much I'm
playing it by myself which is not a fun
time it is it is like the most stressful
time you could possibly have in a game
I'm better at killing things but that
doesn't mean that I'm good at killing
things it is still just a big old
problem 90% of the time that's something
else I hear if you strike air nothing
happens and you don't need a fully
charged one to kill these guys
maybe late fine yeah great is there one
up here is that what I'm hearing no I
also love like D ambience great the
music's great the sense of impending
loneliness and doom is great it's not
even a bending loneliness it's just
loneliness because I'm alone ammo pack
yes please
the good news is all the drops go to me
[Music]
there's one over there but I think it's
far enough way that it's gonna be fine
oh well you were beeping but good thing
you were far enough away I am being way
more jazzed up than I need to be all
right you're oh oh I swear I was much
better when I wasn't recording and it
looks like it they're not gonna be nice
and they're not gonna give me I lied
they get one one seafoam you suck all
right fine better than none I guess all
right I don't know if this would be
possible without seafoam that is the
other factor I need seafoam grenades
if I don't have seafoam grenades I die
so I'm gonna try to try to do this
properly and by doing that I'm going to
put that down i'ma throw a seafoam at it
and it's gonna gush up and that is
reinforced so now I got to do this and I
got on like this and then I just got to
survive this onslaught and this is like
there's like the make or break at the
beginning of the game I don't know gonna
work now like maybe a 50% success rate
with this thing yeah you get em shoddy
Wulfgar me okay this is ordinarily I
would like to see foam grenades but it
seems like one is gonna get me through
all of these security maybe not maybe
they're gonna get through quick hole
maybe they're gonna get through quick oh
maybe they're gonna get through quick oh
I'm a bad shot right now did I get him I
got it okay
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] God I'm missing [ __ ] come on
oh don't be like this to me
okay reload this big it's just arranged
dudes oh yeah get shot yeah there's my
shotgun oh yeah babe how did I miss you
whoa okay that could have gone better
but also it could have gone worse so
that's that's not too shabby I'll take
that
did I miss a medkit somewhere I did
thank goodness all the resources are for
me okay this is where I always die
I should mention I've never actually
done it on my own in practice so I don't
actually know what I'm talking about
why did I hear someone Dushan and
throbbing over there I don't know I
don't think they should beginning its
excited about my presence just yet glow
sticks God glow sticks you'll love to
see it you'll love to see it you know an
x-ray I'll take some it screw it chuck
them chuck him and get him out the door
OOP what's down there who's down there
oh hi sorry bud didn't mean it these
only last a minute so they do not last
long
Wow hi didn't notice you good god screw
this noise
you'll love to see oh you love to see it
these guys are everywhere God you were
there you were there the whole time
hello were you there for they are really
really all over the place now why are
you doing that what is doing that it is
just douching up behind me I've never
experienced that ever okay so I'm
looking for a key I didn't look what key
I needed but I'm sure I'll find it not
dealing with that right now
I don't need to deal with that let's not
deal with that we don't need to deal
with it so why would I deal with it I
don't know what's going on the other
side of that wall I don't like it I
don't like it okay so there's one down
here one there okay that's fine you are
by yourself you should be able to be
killed it's all good it's fine
floor refill you love to see it you love
to see it you just love to see it I love
to see it
you love to see it we all love to see it
okay so I gotta be stealthy stealthy
wealthy about this it's not the closest
one or is there another in front of me
hmm I think that's the closest one okay
it should know there was boo it turns
out I should be able to kill this guy
I thought he was waking up I don't know
why panic like that that is not what
you're supposed to do I swear to God
that is not the proper protocol for
taking care of these guys but you can
hit them if they're close so long as the
other one that's not in range is not
blowing like that oh my god oh my god oh
that was the one I thought there was two
like right here but I mean it was close
enough that it was gonna be a problem so
it's probably for the best that I did
okay there's a little more stressful
than I was hoping for but I'm getting
I'm getting far I've never really gotten
this far I've gotten this far like once
halfway through this room and then I
there was like a tentacle man and then I
died that's pretty much the end of my
story there it's gonna use one of these
for now I've got plenty of ammo actually
it's okay no it's okay it's okay it's
okay
are you far enough away Wow
you dropped like a rock to think you're
alone
my heart is pounding give you the one
over there one over there god there's so
many where's this one I know I heard it
who I don't see it why don't more there
you are oh [ __ ]
that's not good you hate to see it yeah
I'm gonna go in oh no it was nothing a
lot of nothing happening over here
god damn it one of these guys better
give me seafoam I literally cannot do
the next segment if I don't have seafoam
oh yeah right give me a give me a full
oh there's no way why did I even try to
do this is frickin impossible
I think the other ones close enough that
I should not hit this guy until that one
over there right there finishes doing
its thing we're gonna go night-night
I think that's everything anybody hear
anything else I asked the void no one
can answer me because I'm alone all
right we're good
probably long-range flash like that's
totally useful for me that's great
I love that that's just peachy was there
like another hidden case in the darkness
over here no Locker up here really this
is really this is the treatment I get
this is what I get I get I get a whole
lot of nothing I get a whole lot of
nothing I get no seafoam grenades I get
no nothing there was only one seafoam
grenade in the other area and a whole
lot of nothing okay do I have to go up
here the good news is we're reaching new
areas so there's that I don't even think
we made it here when we were playing
together me and my friends who I miss
very dearly at this moment that's some
weird sound
why's that audio playing okay actually I
think we might have made it here once I
don't know if we get to the end of it
though I'm just hoping for some good
good that good [ __ ]
I hope this has the good [ __ ] in it oh
hey Wow
okay I got the key this is new territory
I actually have the key okay so here's
how this works out if I get the key and
I go back to the key room and I'm able
to get through that alive and then I'm
very careful to the next areas all I
have to do is grab the sample and then
run that's it set up my sentry at the
end run the extraction doesn't take that
long I extract an out and I've done it
whether or not that's possible remains
to be seen but that is the general idea
behind my strategy at the moment and
insanely enough it looks like I might
actually have a shot at this but before
I do that I really truly desperately
need seafoam so I got to keep exploring
other areas here because if I don't have
seafoam I am dead in the water
legitimately I have no chance because if
I can't see from that door I don't have
enough defense to get the security
measures undone and my turret won't have
enough time to start hammering away at
the dudes who are hammering at the door
so let's hope there's yeah go six you
love to see it know you love it you love
it you don't need anyway I just what I'm
gonna do is I'm not gonna try to kill
anything I'm just gonna trip I'm gonna
go in here I'm gonna look for items I'm
going to get out that is legitimately
the only way that I'm gonna survive this
there's a box there okay okay okay okay
I got one seafoam grenade which is good
that's good if I find another however
it's bad because they're not stackable
we just I think they're clear oversight
on that sake if the developers
developers if I was able to get more
seafoam and stack them that'd be school
[Music]
Oh coming back down oh that's that's
good stuff that's good stuff you love to
see if you love to see you love I love
to see it hi am I out of the range of
[ __ ] am i out of range oh is that
another big guy
I've been around with two big guys and
and tentacle man
oh this was the worst room to come into
I'm just gonna scan this next room here
I'm gonna look I might have missed
another box in here
I would never know cuz I couldn't help
looks clear to me
except E as hell a lot of nothing in
here are you alone are you alone are you
alone please tell me here alone are you
alone are you alone you look alone I'm
just waiting to be sure that you are in
fact alone okay
I'm gonna climb up here and hope there's
nothing
screw it I'm out
oh hi screw I'm out I'm out I'm just out
I am
wait is that another box oh did I see
another box I don't think so
I don't think so oh yah yah yah yah yah
yah yah
is it worth it let me work it put that
my thing down twist it and reverse it
it's your flim flam yet I am just gonna
close this door because to be honest
nothing good can come from there nothing
good nothing good not a good thing in
the world could come out of that dude I
wish I had another seafoam grenade
this level has been pretty stingy to me
but that being said it may be it's
possible
I don't I don't think so
God the drips Jesus Christ I came into
this level of such confidence I came to
the little level with incredible
confidence okay
no time like the present okay here we go
I'm going to that I am going to die I am
going to die I am going to die Oh got a
kill
that's nice you'll love to see it you'll
love to see it Oh God Oh God okay kill
skills after kills kills on kills ooh
that's not good
Oh God already Oh God I know there's
another layer of red oh god here we go
oh my god there's so many of you all got
there nah roads running okay let's go
through I'm gonna go through here I'm
gonna close this door oh my god
I know I'm not done in there but you
know that's all I got oh [ __ ] there Oh
God
Wow okay this ain't good
is what this is what the kids at school
call not good oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh you know what ah let's get out of
here
I got a skedaddle I got I got I got a
hot date oh yeah where's my bed med kit
med pack there it is Oh God
kill him kill him kill him kill him
okay I'm going back in security scan
don't mind if I do
ooh oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god hi
oh that's not good okay I need to go now
oh god I'm gonna just I'll be right back
with you oh my god oh my god I don't
even know if running away is even gonna
be remotely effective nope cuz I'm gonna
die run oh I think you could probably
get that with enough attempts but I am
not patient enough to try it maybe I'll
try it again someday but that was about
as good as those attempts could have
gone in thankfully I was recording at
the time that it did it would take a lot
more effort to get through that with my
skin intact
hey that's this game is not meant to be
played with one person
I'm currently operating under the
assumption that this absolutely will not
work I only have to see foams but
crazier things have happened here we go
the fun begins oh that's not what I
wanted
you hate to see
oh wait actually holy [ __ ]
is that for real oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
oh I didn't I didn't finish that one
yeah this is how it fails I always get
oh [ __ ] are you kidding me
whoo wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait for it oh my god oh my
god
these guys won't die there we go you're
not dead are you please tell me I'm
recording and it's working Oh
oh my god
I just did it with two sea foam grenades
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I didn't even blow all
my minds wonder if these ones in here
even actually did anything okay so they
did so the thing I did differently is I
placed mines in here I didn't know if
they came from here and I think they
like pick a random direction it just
depends so I tried to cover all my bases
and this door didn't even oh my god I
lucked out oh my god I really lucked out
I must have focused exactly where they
were coming from
and blew up like the entire wave which
gave me more time to finish the things I
also set up coming from so I bet they I
bet what happened is they came from this
direction first and then they came from
this direction so I lucked out on the
RNG of the direction they were coming
from which happens to be the two paths
that I mind the heaviest because I left
some redundancies just in case things
were coming from other places but
apparently I didn't even need to do that
that's insane
that's bonkers oh [ __ ] okay so I'm not
out of the woods yet
this is not the end of the road holy
[ __ ] this is not even like a good run
this run went horribly for me I wasn't
recording it but it went real bad holy
[ __ ]
okay so to explain the differences it's
been like days since that other attempt
that you probably just saw depending on
how I'm going to edit this it's been
days I changed up from shotgun sentry to
ah while I was really dark there oh
that's just it's broken for some reason
I don't know why whatever it's been days
so I changed from shotgun sentry to mine
I focused on just trying to get enough
sea foam to get through this portion
here with my life intact and I figured
that if I could do that if I could have
at least three seafoam I'd be able to
block up that door long enough to be
able to undo the security sequence of
which there are three unfortunately but
fortunately for me I lucked out on the
placement of the the mines right down to
the I mean well everything holy crap
yeah okay so I need to refocus because
I'm not done yet is the thing I need to
go get Hsu blah blah blah and oh boy oh
god um I need to get Hsu and then I need
to evacuate and in order to evacuate I
have to get Hsu and then run to the
beginning and then fight off the people
long enough to not die and that's the
thing I have to make it to the end and
not die shouldn't be too hard
oh okay
so the thing is I've gotten pretty good
at taking out these dudes it's actually
not too difficult even if they like wake
up you can generally oh you're not dead
okay
that was dumb of me so I said I got real
good at it and then I screw up right
there um but it actually is not that bad
to take them out so long as you're don't
panic after you do it you just sit
around waiting for your upper - I hear
something clicking to the left which is
why I'm with you and then you just stay
calm after you hit him don't move the
biggest thing that triggers is after
they hit them after anyone hits like an
enemy they move even if it's a tiniest
bit that matters like you want to hit
and stay still and make sure that
nothing else is clicking and looking up
at the time that you are about to hit it
is there anything up here I thought I
heard something Oh God
there you are yeah it's important to
just freeze like if you shine a light on
something you're fine just freeze don't
move
don't panic
stay still oh there's a lot of them in
here I have not been to this area in so
long just because I've been trying the
same thing over and over again for ages
now it feels like ages anyway if you're
slow and methodical like nothing can get
in your way you just you basically just
do even with tentacle guys
there's so many nice chin think I
cleared the room okay so I just need to
see if there's any items in here the
only thing that I would need at this
point is maybe more toolkits I need some
health because I want to top off but I'm
not in a bad place
but other than that like I am super
happy I am very very happy I haven't
even thought about my strategy going
into the last portion of this because I
didn't actually believe that I would get
there well well well seafoam grenade
that is very handy I'm actually gonna
save this for the run back I'm gonna
keep my light it's because it's useful
for finding items but yeah that's
actually gonna be very helpful for the
run back because if I can keep them out
like outside the circle if I could foam
up like that area there then this is
gonna bode well for me okay so I'm not
gonna forget that those are right there
and I'm gonna grab those before the end
am i recording please tell me I'm
recording and everything's fine
everything is fine everything is fine
everything's fine probably definitely
okay let's see what the stitches over
here
sucks to be cool kit I'll take that you
know what I'll take that because what I
can do is I can preemptively mine well
hopefully actually maybe I shouldn't
because what if I'm running back in them
ones right behind me and then it blasts
me and then game over because of my own
stupidity okay this seems pretty good I
don't hear anything this is where all
the seafoam was I was waiting for you uh
whatever it's fine cuz that'll be good
because then before I get it I can see
foam my path out with a lot of seafoam
it's just like icing on the cake you
know what I'm gonna do actually is I'm
going to grab this seafoam and I'm going
to prep it and by prep it I mean I'm
gonna place it ahead so that I can grab
it once I reach my destination and then
bada-bing bada-boom so if you see like
allistic so one thing blow sticks are
good for is you can use them do swap
things out so now seafoam is right here
by the exit so I can grab it when I need
it
there are enemies in here but I think
this is the final room anyway no more
tentacles by the sound of it
you by yourself okay it doesn't sound
like there's a lot in here I've gotten
really good at hearing these things so
that's good
I don't know what useful skill that's
gonna be in literally any other
situation but I've gotten very good at
hearing clicks and knowing where they're
coming from are you by yourself
no you were not I've also discovered you
don't quite need a full headshot you can
want them on there but I think those the
last 100 don't do that to me okay there
it is okay this is what I need it
perfect so this is two uses so then all
that's left to do is find hsu 194 well
194 okay there it is okay that's the one
so this is my path out I go this way
I go this way I'm literally going to
mine where I am NOT going so this path
it's mined
because I say so I'm going to close and
mine this door because I'm not going
that way
here because I say so I could mine this
because I don't want anything coming
there how much is this screw it let's
just make this kind of like a walled off
area that wouldn't hit me only are the
places I can think of would be there and
I could keep them from trying to flank
me a little bit yeah um [ __ ] this is it
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] yeah I'm uh I guess I'm
ready
holy [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
I've got four med kits I've got two
mines full ammo full health okay I've
got the seafoam I'm going to chuck this
wherever I need to in case of emergency
otherwise I'm going to run straight
through everything I'm gonna hit these
doors on the way out okay this is it
there's nothing else to prepare for I
just go that's all it is I just go holy
[ __ ]
alright let's do this I'm as prepared as
I can be alright we're doing this
just gotta stay calm and collected calm
and collected
that's all yep here it starts
oh [ __ ] throw one of these they're
running running
maybe I should it should have phoned
that up I think I think in my brain I
like thought about foaming it and then
didn't quite get there okay
[Music]
okay 20% doing good so far
39 they're breaking through that other
side door over there okay they hit a
grenade 5060 oh my god
oh you hit my trap tried to flank me oh
my god oh my god
haw haw [ __ ] oh oh my god I'm like
shaking
holy [ __ ] oh my god oh my god I did it I
[ __ ] did it
I holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] holy crap I did it
I'm not the first to get that done but
holy crap I did it and I didn't even
have the ideal thing I thought I needed
absolutely needed
three maybe even four seafoam for that
key door but no it's just proper mind
placement and good evacuation route
being able to kill things as quick as
you can being very stealthy and thorough
and a little bit of luck like there's
always that little bit of luck factor
but holy crap I can't believe it Wow
okay so that is a one of the rundown I
think that's probably the only one that
you'd be able to do solo I cannot
imagine how you would do any of the
other ones solo maybe it's possible but
this one was like the number of like
heed or things and things like that it's
just is it gets harder the farther you
go down so I have no idea I'm just very
proud of myself
I mean mad like you'd understand like
probably like 12 hours of truck and now
I'm really good at the game but I
haven't even gotten down to be weird and
gotten to see man I love this game this
game is phenomenal if you guys aren't
playing this game oh my god get this
game find some friends there's an act of
discord where you can find groups
they're working on matchmaking just this
is a great experience
terrifying heart-pounding but in the
best way so thank you everybody so much
for watching look forward more gtfo
coming at you soon
thankfully with my friends because
that's the way this game is meant to be
played but I am now in a small group of
people that have beaten a one by myself
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next bye bye
[Music]